[Music]
the loss of chemical combinations
created ripples in the stagnant pool of
chemistry they enabled scientists to
carry out various experiments that help
in forming strong foundations in
chemistry however the law still needed
experimental evidences and proofs only
then would they be accepted it was
around the first decade of the 19th
century that a chemist and a physicist
from England named John Dalton was
successful in answering many questions
he proposed a theory which was then
known as the Dalton's atomic theory with
this theory many concepts regarding
matter composition of matter atoms and
even combinations of atoms resulting in
compounds but better understood okay
let's first take a very quick look at
the six major postulates of his theory
first he said that all matter is made up
of very tiny particles called atoms
secondly he suggested that atoms are
indivisible particles which cannot be
created or destroyed in a chemical
reaction third postulate was atoms of a
given element are identical in mass and
chemical properties similarly fourth
postulate was that atoms of different
elements have different masses and
chemical properties fifth postulate
stated that atoms combine in a ratio of
small whole numbers to form compounds
and lastly the relative number and kinds
of atoms are constant in a given
compound I know I just rattled off the
postulates don't worry let us now
understand each postulate one by one by
taking the same example of elements a
and B giving rise to compound C the
first point stated that all matter is
made up of very tiny particles called
atoms it means that when we go on
dividing matter into smaller and smaller
sections what we get at the end is atoms
so can we say that elements a and B are
made up of atoms yes in fact compound C
is also made up of atoms that have
combined together
so the first postulate was very easy to
understand the second postulate was that
atoms are indivisible particles which
cannot be created or destroyed in a
chemical reaction now what do we mean by
this yes it means that atoms are like
the fundamental units dividing them
further is not possible also in a
chemical reaction atoms may combine
together to form new units however no
new atoms can be created and existing
ones cannot be destroyed so in this case
the atoms of element a and B are just
combining to form compound C so can we
say that no new atoms are formed in this
case yes and similarly no atom is
destroyed let's move on to the third one
now the third postulate states that
atoms of a given element are identical
in mass and chemical properties if we
zoom into the element a we find all the
atoms that make up element a are just
the same and in what sense are these
same the atoms have identical mass as
well as chemical properties in simple
words the third postulate states that
all atoms of a given element are
identical and dusters explain the fourth
postulate to yes
the fourth postulate states that atoms
of different elements have different
masses and chemical properties so I'll
be able to notice that atoms in element
a are different from those in element B
absolutely and in what sense are they
different atoms in element a and B have
different masses and even different
chemical properties in simple words
it states that atoms of different
elements are different the fifth
postulate states that atoms combine in a
ratio of small whole numbers to form
compounds now what do we mean by this in
this chemical reaction we find elements
a and B reacting and giving us the
compound see a field serve well are you
of compound c has two atoms of element a
and one atom of element B right so
aren't these whole numbers yes this
means that in any compound the elements
are always present in a ratio which
comprises of whole numbers you will not
find 1/2 or 3/4 atom combining with the
other in case of water we always have
two hydrogen atoms and one oxygen atom
combining to form one unit in one unit
of carbon dioxide we have one carbon and
two oxygen atoms the same holds true for
all compounds the number of atoms of a
particular element in a compound will
always be a whole number now for the
last one the sixth postulate states that
the relative number and kinds of atoms
are constant in a given compound the
same explanation that compounds C has
two atoms of element a and one of
element B makes us understand this yes
if we scand compound c we will always
find two atoms of element a and one atom
of element b in a single unit and this
is applicable for all compounds we've
already looked at two examples water and
carbon dioxide in case of one unit of
water we always have two hydrogen atoms
and one oxygen atom and in a single unit
of carbon dioxide we have one carbon and
two oxygen atoms carbon monoxide has one
atom of each that is carbon and oxygen
while one unit of ammonia always has one
nitrogen atom bound to three hydrogen
atoms so the number of atoms will always
be constant in a unit of a particular
compound in a nutshell all these
postulates help chemists to further
understand behaviors of elements and the
compounds formed from them but for
understanding these elements and
compounds knowing the concept of atoms
is necessary let's get to know what
exactly these atoms are how they exist
their mass and many such interesting
concepts
in the upcoming videos
[Music]